tenía obsesión por los palacios
construyó decenas en Bagdad y en otros
lugares del país como ticrito pero este
en especial en Babel en Babilonia tiene
un valor especial para él él construyó
esta colina donde construyó este Palacio
que nos encontramos y aquí podía ver
todas las ruinas de Babilonia sobre las
que él había construido lo que se
llamaba esa nueva Babilonia aquí en las
instrucciones en estas piedras no
solamente se ve su imagen sino el
símbolo de su de su dictadura de su
gobierno que identificaba a sadán y se
ve toda la ostentación un palacio
hermoso porque se ve está rodeado por el
río éufrates y de aquí se ven todos
estos sembrados de palmeras que eran
míticos en esta Babilonia como en todos
los palacios de Sadam este Palacio fue
saqueado por la población pocos días
después del ingreso de las tropas
estadounidenses que entraron por el sur
del país tomaron la zona de basura
controlaron todas estas regiones
petroleras y rápidamente fue cayendo el
ejército y llegaron a esta parte de
Babilonia y aquí en estas Explanada
crearon una base militar Y este Palacio
se convirtió también en una base de los
norteamericanos Pero antes había sido
saqueado ya por la población iraquí los
americanos se fueron de esa zona en el
2005 se retiraron de todo el país en el
2011 pero como vemos este Palacio ha
quedado básicamente destrozado no han
vuelto a recuperarlo la población puede
entrar básicamente sin ningún control
hay algunas autoridades pero como vemos
en todas una de estas paredes hay
pintadas de memorias mensajes de la
población y se ve en un estado bastante
lamentable hoy por ejemplo había
graduación de decenas de jóvenes que
habían venido de Bagdad pero también los
niños de la región vienen aquí a jugar a
falta de parques Así que ese es el
estado de este Palacio al cual tiene
acceso a la población a otros no tiene
acceso especialmente por ejemplo en
Bagdad o anticript donde es originario